بعد اقل من 40 و 20 ساعه عن تفجير الذي هز
شارع تقسيم في العاصمه الاقتصاديه تركيه
اسطنبول اكدت انقره اعتقالها الشخص الذي
زرع القنبله كما وجهت اصابع الاتهام الى
حزب العمال الكردستاني وحملته مسؤوليه
الاعتداء الذي اسفر عن سته قتل على الاقل
مباشره الجرحى
منذ فتره وجيزه تم اعتقاله الشخص الذي نفذ
الهجوم ووضع القنبله من قبل فرق شرطه
اسطنبول
وزير الداخليه التركي اكد ان الامر
بالهجوم على شارع الاستقلال صدر في مدينه
كوباني بشمال سوريا حيث قامت القوات
التركيه بعمليه ضد وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه السوريه في السنوات الاخيره مضيفا
ان منفذ التفجير امر عبر منطقه عفرين قبل
ان يصل الى اسطنبول
هذا واثار الاعتداء الذي ياتي قبل سبعه
اشهر من الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه
ادانات عده من باكستان الى الهند ومن
ايطاليا الى فرنسا والمانيا حيث تقيم
جاليه تركيه كبيره وكذلك من السعوديه وقطر
والكويت والبحرين والاردن كما نجدت
الولايات المتحده بتفجير مشيره الى انها
ستقف فوج الارهاب جنبا الى جنب مع تركيا
حلفتها في حلف شمال الاطلسي